all right
[Music]
uh let's say let's say he's gonna throw
a jab and he's gonna throw a jab at me
okay so uh kimazubi is throws his jab I
follow that jab back in
right
you have kimisubi here too
and the Hand goes up I have to follow it
up
so if we have these drills here right
we're here like that
and uh his hands are on my hand ready
put your hand on mine okay
um
and he brings his hand up into his
showman you see he goes up and I follow
it up
goes up that's not Cuba City okay
yeah
and uh I'm on this side
okay in my forms
and he's gonna sugiashi to the rear to
free his sword with Kitty guy
you see ready so he goes up this is not
key Mississippi
he goes I stay with it and it goes right
does not lose connection you see that
we'll do it again so you can't see
so I have the IP adhesion he goes I keep
ik adhesion and I go to the next Ikea
teaching connection point
got it okay so
uh we're here if this is too late
here so I move with him
I'll move with him
we do the other side I move with him
I move with him
I enter with him
endure with him
he's here with him
every single time
if I'm late
you're gonna clash and it's gonna come
down
if you can touch his wrist
got it do you see
you caught it coming down because
the hand
I can't touch this
you see I can't touch his wrist okay
so I'd like for you to use
concept of keema City
the
physiological index point I can't touch
his wrist
and therefore my hands go here
right here
so the tegatana is on the tricep tendon
of insertion
on the other hand is just North of it
towards the shoulder okay
then his energy is going to come down
now
when his energy comes down where do you
think that goes anyone can answer
where am I going to take it
to a rotation nope
that's your problem
I'm not going to take it into a rotation
okay the first thing I do he goes cool
and I'm gonna project do you see and
I'll project him look look at where we
are now do you see if the camera comes
over there
where do you go
he's off the line and now I can enter
here it's ever so it's not an external
thing it becomes an extra little thing
after the projection okay
so I'm going to come around and bring
the camera back around over to this side
it is his hands coming down I started to
rotate
this half will come
from the ticketana around
just below the elbow because again I
can't reach that okay just below the
elbow and now it's trapped in here
push
pull on the circle boom
[Music]
here
so I would do it again and you'll watch
for that I love with him there's a
tricep tentative assertion he props down
boom I move that over I come around
there it is right there
boom
and again I'm at the end
so do it again team assuming
around
[Music]
get those hand placements please go
okay my last point was don't don't make
it into a leverage technique so I'm not
gonna go here and then I push pulled you
see
do this that's not what I'm doing the
only goal of this Push Pull is to stop
his hand from posting
same thing
so it doesn't it's not a huge lever it
doesn't require much of an engine
you see he'll reach for the ground but I
keep bringing it around
[Music]
boom comes around and I just don't want
his hand to post
you see that I can't get his wrist again
if you're gaming it and your UK is not
prone to strike you can grab his wrist
but it's full speed his wrist will not
be there his his arm goes into the cut
you see so all you have is this and all
you need to do is keep this hand from
posting
that's it
so as I go that's all I'm doing
this side is doing the technique
this time but he'll post on you
sure
okay let's try it again
we gotta go back to the test sabaki okay
so uh
this this hand right here right this is
the key machine behind his hand goes up
to his head and I follow it up okay
yeah but that hand that hand that hand
is actually uh
there's there's only uh there's only the
fire Spyro and then the water spider
so I I have the end and I have the
outward that's all I have okay so when
his hand goes up you have the inward
spiral it just stops at the top and then
heals okay
and then uh my outward spiral do you
think
so these two hands meet right Fire and
Water right there you see that so this
this hand
because it is
The Perennial philosophy
from another point of view
that is also the fire hand
can you see it if he stands up and grabs
me with his left hand
sorry right hand you see this is it
right there
do you see that can you see that
so it's both fire and water is going at
the same time
you see so to do those hands it's not
here
do you see that wrist that that's not
correct
this risk has to spiral into its pattern
this isn't it either
boom here
so okay now I'm here now I have a
different relationship with him and now
as I come around I don't want to go here
that's what you're doing
you see my elbow on this this side right
here okay what I do instead is just
blend blend blend till your hand falls
because it's gonna fall because you're
striking and then I right there
you guys see that
so well some of you are in weird shapes
this
those aren't your shapes you'll you only
have you only have that inverse spiral
and the outward spiral which is the same
spiral okay
can you see it okay and then I move
until his hand gets
to that opening I take the opening at
his hand gate
I don't go and actively seek it
boom his hands dropping it drops into my
other hand again
who says dropping it drops into the
other half
so first
fix how you get make contact and then be
patient let it go till it's a natural
movement and not you going over the top
okay
try it again